ماركات السيارات الرياضيه الكبرى ستجدها
في الاسواق دراجات هوائيه كهربائيه ستطور
بورشه ايباي باحدث المحركات والبطاريات
الكهربائيه والبرامج الحاسوبيه الخاصه
بالدراجات وتضع خطه كبيره لعام 2005
تشير الماركه الرياضيه الى انها تهدف
للاستحواذ على 80% من اجمالي مبيعات السوق
سنه 2030 وستكون رائده في مجال التنقل
المستدامه وذلك على الرغم من ان دراجتها
سيصل سعرها الى 8000 يورو مقارنه بالفين
او ثلاثه الاف يورو لمركات الدراجات من
علامات منتشره حاليا من جانبها دخلت ماركه
ميني كوبر مجال الدراجات الكهربائيه مع
الاعلان الاخير لشركه انجل للدراجات
الذكيه بانها ستصمم وتصنع في فرنسا طرازا
من الدرجات الكهربائيه لميني كوبر ايضا
نجحت رينو نهايه عام 2022 بتسويق دراجات
سباق تدخل الياف الكربون في صناعتها بسعر
9000 يورو ومن تصميم شركه لابيا بهدف
الترويج لمركتها الرياضيه البين اطلقت
شركات كثيره اخرى دراجاتها الهوائيه او
مركبات سكوتر في المرحله الاخيره من امثال
لمبرجيني وبوجاتي
[موسيقى]